servus es geht zwar herzlich willkommen
zur lang ersehnten ruptur und ich würde
sagen bevor wir darum reden starten wir
direkt mal in die reinheit und sehen uns
nach dem intro wieder
so ich stehe jetzt hier vor meiner
zimmertür und wir vermerkt habe ist der
ton bisher anders als beim iphone auf
dementsprechendes der ton nicht so der
hammer aber ich glaube da geht das
gleiche thema angehört und ja es sind
sicher viele drauf gefreut auf diese
kultur darf mache ich das erst mal der
erste teil des specials und ich bezahle
den zweiten teil verrate ich euch im
laufe des videos jetzt auch richtig
richtig geil aber zuallererst sonst war
das hier an
guck mal hier das poster habe ich an
meiner wand hängen ich dachte jetzt
nicht geht nicht die ist einfach in die
hocheffektive machen hier bibi und tina
und das hab ich nur hier dran hängen
weil dieser tief wir einfach so aussieht
die max also mein bruder krankhafter
wenn du das auch für könnte es in die
kommentare schreiben
ich finde das einfach so krass wie sieht
genauso aus wie der mann das spiel
einfach mit falls ihr wissen wollt wäre
es ist ich glaube finde ich gerade den
namen hier
louis haters der kollege können ja mal
nachschauen gucken ob der nicht ausgehen
ich würde sagen jetzt starten wir mal
rein
ja bestimmt lustig für euch jetzt ja die
sache lange hier nur aus dieser
perspektive gesehen war es immer aber
erst mal die tür zu wollen ja nicht die
ganze wohnung zeigen sondern um einen
moment ich hatte jetzt bewusst auf dem
boden damit ihr euch jetzt zu zeigen
kann so die perspektive kennt ihn an
diesen schlüssel rumhängt und das
hypozentrum stuhl so nämlich
normalerweise auf jetzt drehen wir das
alles mal um und zwar in 3 21
so sieht das aus bei mir das ist der
rechner auf dem ich alles machen das ist
mein laptop ein lenovo hier z 570 mit
kleiner aufrüstung ich habe eine ssd
reingemacht als meine festplatte
ich habe vier gigabyte karte bis habe
ich grafikkarte vier gigabyte
arbeitsspeicher extra ein gemacht dank
nehme ich alles auf hier sind wir gerade
auf meiner privaten facebook für das
kann man nicht erkennen
so könnt ihr ab juli sind ist doch
angeschlossen na ja wohl aber auf jeden
fall ist das hier mein mikro da handelt
es sich um ein
hier kann man sehen und zwar ein team
osc 440 an irgend einem x-beliebigen
millennium ständer hinsieht ist okay bei
hallo gesagt alles klar
hier ist mein kleiderschrank ist auch
relativ dick und das ein paar schuhe
mein gott ja und jetzt eine umsetzungs
mal kurz hin
auf diesen wunderschönen stuhl auf dem
jamaa zocker des orange juice pack is to
be true die so wir locken zwar erstmal
hier aus diesen facebook facebook aus
würde ich mal sagen und machen wir einen
kleinen klitzekleinen katze wieder diese
seite dürft ihr kennen das ist mein
channel und wir sind hier links ab ob
meine hallo
aber was viel spannender ist hier recht
dass meine maus das ist eine razer
imperator hier ist die packung dazu ich
habe mir die nicht illegal gedownloadet
sondern ganz normal gekauft und sie
fragt man kann auch mal zehn minuten
etwas natürlich nicht als mousepad habe
ich ein
roccat taito sittinger das finde ich
ganz gerne mit version
ganz ehrlich ich krieg 12 millionen von
locke dafür reicht es jetzt die sage
vielen dank deswegen produzieren razer
mouse weil logge mich von sotschi
natürlich ich bin leider nicht
gesponsert
aber fakt ist dass hier sind meine
kopfhörer das sind sennheiser ich feiere
so sehen heißt es zu tode
ebenso sennheiser sponsert mich mit
ungefähr drei millionen im jahr
die köpfe habe ich mir selbst gekauft es
handelt sich hier um sehen wir dass
gerade irgendwo doch hier ganz in ruhe
kann ich das machen
achtung kann das schaf der moment
kriegsende ja kann der das focus und ich
glaube nicht das szenario auch wir jetzt
könnt ihr sehen okay es handelt sich um
hd 409 und oder 429 kopfhörer finde ich
diese dicken bügel kopfhörer mit denen
ihrer musik auch auf dem fahrrad ist
zwar nicht so legal aber juno und ja
hier hinten
seht ihr meine webcam dabei handelt es
sich um eine microsoft lifecam studio
wie auf einem bücherstapel steht
sozusagen der philosophisch unterbau
hits wie die da unten was ihr was
erkennen kann kein marx und hier oben
noch in einer psychologisch kafka ist
auch irgendwo auf kafka liegt mein
notebook city hier läuft bei mir auf
jeden fall
und ja es handelt sich um eine website
nicht dass dincklage einem microsoft
lifecam studio
die hat hier den denn sieht man hier
einen 1080p hd sensor ziemlich gerne der
1080p fotos mitmachen
für frank nails oder so es ist
eigentlich ganz sauber und nimmt videos
auf in 720 obwohl draufsteht 1080 das
sind ganz schöne schimmel bei microsoft
also bis jetzt ein bisschen geschieht
ist falls ihr das sagen hat mir jetzt
einfach mal keine treffen mehr sondern
nur noch elf aber juli was gibt es
eigentlich noch zu zeigen ja dass hier
ist eine steckdose wunderschön und ja
ich würde fast sagen wir sind schon fast
durch
sie überlege gerade ach ja das kann man
vielleicht mal zeigen hier dass dafür
mir nie fehlen immer so ein bisschen
immer ein bisschen wasser so einen
fetten wassertank 2 liter und ein glas
ich trink wasser wie ein esel was ihr um
sich wasser drängt wahrscheinlich eher
nicht aber auf jeden fall wie ein kamel
locker jeden tag zu 4 5 liter wasser
sind gesund würde ich sagen
also ich darauf wirklich mega viel
wasser zu warm war ein glas nach dem
anderen
und ja ich würde sagen wäre das video
gefallen hat dann gebt mir einen daumen
nach oben schreibt in die kommentare was
ihr euch als nächstes video wünscht wir
könnten mal wieder zu weitere games
machen wir können ende ganz machen und
jetzt eine sache jetzt kommen wir zum
zweiten paket zum zweiten teil des ich
hoffe ich bin im fokus
4k specials und zwar wenn ich max
ein fantreffen machen und das vertreten
stattfinden in berlin will er bock drauf
habt könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben
wer dabei sein will mal ganz interessant
zu wissen wer von meinen leuten so aus
berlin kommt wir werden das verständlich
auf dem alex machen sowie wachsen
letztes gemacht hat vielleicht am
samstag dazu gibt doch genauere infos
aber wenn ihr bock drauf habt schreibt
schon in die kommentare
gibt ein like und ich würde sagen wir
sind jetzt an wieder beim nächsten video
drei macht's gut und ja